disturbing body camera video shows a
violent arrest in Colorado now the
subject of an internal investigation
this is ridiculous
you gotta shot me right in the face this
week the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Office announced it launched an
investigation into the incident as First
Responders use of force comes into
question
because
yes
this is crazy guys
you do what you're told all right you
think it's okay just to roll up on
traffic stop no you're not doing now you
go to jail the incident happened on
November 29th of last year about three
hours south of Denver in Trinidad
Colorado originally sheriff's deputy
Mikhail Noel pulled over Nathan Espinoza
for following too closely to his squad
car
thank you
Windows Frozen okay what's up
Deputy Norwood Sheriff's Office let me
get your driver's license right hold
that dog
a little snippy
that's the problem is what's the problem
yeah yeah you're following too closely
can't you see the roads are icy you see
me slowing down and you're still crew
coming up behind me there's no reason
for you to be doing that it's not good
don't tell me how I should be driving
okay I'm in a mark all right well I mean
that doesn't give you the right to
follow up Mark patrol car close like
that what if I had to stop I know there
is ice there that's why I was cruising
so I don't slip
there's no reason for you to be trapped
but be that close behind a mark patrol
car
[Music]
okay when you find that stay in the
vehicle your registration and insurance
I'll be back
at the time of the incident Espinoza and
his father Kenneth Espinosa were driving
separate vehicles to a garage when
Nathan was pulled over at the traffic
stop Kenneth also pulled over his
vehicle body camera video shows
Lieutenant Henry Trujillo approached his
vehicle thank you
[Applause]
do you need to be behind this traffic
stop yeah why my son right there he was
following me okay he's on a traffic stop
though you don't need to be behind it
oh I'm not being mean we just don't like
when people pull in behind us
that's what we get paid to do to pull
people over you don't get paid
okay I asked you a simple question okay
in fact you need to leave now or you're
going to get charged it's that easy body
camera video then shows the pair arguing
about the father's decision to also pull
over
I'm recording too
I asked you a simple question if you
have an attitude that's your problem
okay on my door yeah you saw me and you
rolled your window up when I came
traffic stopped hold on a second okay no
you rolled your window up no when I
walked up okay so I knocked on your
window okay you're not a cop you don't
need to be behind me okay so you need to
leave no I don't need to do anything
about five seconds to leave okay there's
no reason for you to be behind this
traffic stop no reason okay no reason
okay no reason do I not pay it do you
always stop behind cops when they pull
people over I ain't right behind
you okay you don't need to be here you
don't need to be here okay you need to
go no I don't I'm waiting on myself
Deputy Noel's body camera video shows
what happens next when Lieutenant
Trujillo walks away
[Music]
leave
separate body camera video shows the
incident from another angle
do you see this
of course do you see this get out of the
car you see this are you recording yeah
we're recording it yeah what the hell do
you think you're doing I ain't doing
anything okay yeah you're running
traffic stop and you're trying to drive
away all right
control has nothing to do with anything
okay they don't have jurisdiction over
us
no I got my truck
hold on
I'm not get off the car man I'm get back
over there now trying to just stay there
and Report
video shows officials Tays Kenneth while
attempting to get him into the back seat
of a squad car
no get out
get out the car do you see this
out of the car do you see it are you
recording yeah we're recording it yeah
what the hell do you think you're doing
I ain't doing anything okay now you're
running yeah
sit down is off don't pull away from me
I'm not you're gonna get lit up okay
you're gonna get you're breaking my arm
now hold on I'm gonna get out get out
the off get off the car can you
hold on
just stay there and record
[Applause]
what's going on here
oh God
that's fine
you do what you're told all right you
think it's okay just to roll up a
traffic stop no I'm not doing now you go
to jail
[Applause]
let's go
get in the car get it get in the car
turn around and face the club I'm
already pumped
but moments after Kenneth is seated in
the back seat of the squad he's pulled
out once again
do you have your wallet on you don't do
that man I'm gonna get you out I'm gonna
pastor at you now get out I got my wall
get out now
all right
now
get out the car okay
this is how it's gonna work okay you're
gonna do what you're told to do and
that's it stand up
up against the card spread your feet
[Music]
stop
might as well
this is ridiculous
but quit acting like an idiot
you guys
quit grabbing my arms
lean up against the card
spread your feet apart
Kenneth can be heard saying the
situation is excessive arguing he was
tased in the face
come on guys
come on man
[Music]
this is ridiculous well quit acting like
an idiot are you not I'm like nothing I
got a case of Peace in my lid you guys
shot me right in the damn face
later Deputy Noel can be heard
explaining what happened arguing Kenneth
tried to run him over
while I'm holding on to the car by
having my gun
reverse backs up on the 6th heavy car
while I'm still holding onto the car and
try again he had the car and drive and
he accelerated
First Responders then discussed the
tasing incident before taking the father
to jail
we tried to uh
get him out he was refusing and then
when we tried to put him in he was
refusing so I tased him but he fell back
so one hit him here one hit him in the
skin or something so who haven't met I'm
gonna take a look at him and then I
tried to get him out the pastor and get
his wallet because he wouldn't tell me
anything and then that's when that's
when you rolled up okay
I'm gonna get him over to the jail okay
Kenneth Espinoza was originally charged
with resisting arrest and assaulting a
police officer but those charges have
since been dropped his attorney says he
plans to file a civil suit against the
Sheriff's Office reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie